all right we're jumping straight into
this one last season there were some
absolutely heavy hitters we got ufotable
just completely flexing
the attacks of asian money my dress up
darling no our dress up darling and of
course let's not forget attack on titan
final season episode 12 chapter 4 remix
second gig part 2.1 you cannot rumble
these were some big titles but this
season looks like we've got way more to
choose from spy x family is starting
kagia summer is back we've got like 10
new different shows that have genuinely
caught my interest it is looking good it
is looking bright it is looking oh
oh hello what's this
[Music]
egg
you should do ballet give me one good
reason i should do ballet
well what do you think
you've heard of daddy longlegs well get
ready for
mummy longnecks right i know a bunch of
you gonna skip this because la dee da
it's an anime about ballet but damn does
this look like he has potential coming
straight from studio mapper just flexing
their animation the dancing scenes are
bursting with life and energy that
absolutely engrossed me it honestly
looks gorgeous with zero cg in sight
this has the making of a great sports
anime mixed with billy elliot but i also
remember what happened when they did
yuri or nice so we'll have to wait to
see if they're able to maintain this
fantastic quality throughout until then
just look at these necks
[Music]
[Music]
but before we get to our next show a
quick word from our sponsor hi there i
couldn't help but notice that beautiful
head of hair you have don't you want to
make sure you have it for as long as
possible well thankfully today's episode
is sponsored by keeps they offer
clinically proven treatments to combat
the simpsons of hair loss that gets
delivered straight to your door by me
i'll do it myself if you keep your
lovely hair don't lose yet don't you
dare lose you don't lose that hair
disclaimer giga will not actually
deliver the product straight to your
door with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor office or pharmacy and best of
all you can choose a routine that works
for you whether you're looking to
prevent hair loss stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of your hair
keeps has got you covered as someone
who's gone through the sasuke hair phase
and the yakuza hair phase i gotta say i
love both looks but i like having the
choice of which one i want to look like
dear god please not let it be the saska
hair look again you can easily subscribe
to keeps and get refilled reminders so
you'll never run low on the products you
need to take care of your hair stop your
hair loss today with keeps to get 50 off
your first order go to keeps.com or
click the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash gig thanks to
keeps the sponsoring this video and with
that said back to the video back in the
sequel corner we somehow got another
season of data live there's more black
rock shooter comey sign is still
deciding whether talking is a good thing
it's still bad shield heroes still
deciding whether slavery is a bad thing
it's still good oh hey more cargill
summer
oh hey mauricio guy
yeah
all right just hear me out there are so
many shows that use some self-aware meta
twist on the isekai cliches that being
meta has become cliche itself because
almost all of them just changed some
cheap element like what if the
protagonist was an op for once so it's
rare when you see a show that's actually
got some thought put into it here's a
world where isekai is commonplace in
fact so many people from japan have been
isekai's there they've made the ultimate
isekai starter town japan too so in this
kind of world what do you think would
happen if we give a bunch of normal
people superpowers and transport them to
a fantasy world they have no investment
in defeat the demon lord save the world
and respect women hell no they're gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] up ruin things that maybe
respect women so here the native
inhabitants have needed to make an
organization around assassinating people
that have been isocard before they
become a threat to the world that's
right we're so bored of the escape
protagonist that we have now made a show
focus around killing them is that like a
personal attack or something the show is
hella meta but not in a way that seems
gimmicky or cheap the tropes we are so
familiar with have been used to shape
the world and it feels like real thought
has been put into how it was built from
the ground up this is one of the most
intriguing concepts i've seen for isa
kyle in a while and i'm excited to see
where this one goes but that's not the
only one we got a guy who wakes up in an
atomic game he was forced to complete
100 so now he's in an irl new game plus
except he absolutely hated the game with
a fiery passion so he just uses his
knowledge to [ __ ] up all the [ __ ] for
all the characters he hates in the game
and also there's max actual 2d mechs in
an isekai i wasn't lying when i said
before that there is more variety and
new and unique isekai concepts now more
than ever hey it's overlord
anyway as i was saying tokyo esperanto
[Applause]
finally there's potential for modern
good football anime none of this futsal
[ __ ] none of this american rugby [ __ ]
just some good old football if there's
one studio i trust with sports anime
it's production ig and football is the
one sport i really want a new great
anime for because maybe for once maybe
just maybe i'll be able to wrap my head
around the [ __ ] offside rule seems
like this is going to be on the more
realistic side of things but i'm
definitely interested to see what kind
of special anime moves these players
will get
he's going to use the secret technique
the secret technique
flying low what the cucumber has left
the salad
what men are from mars and women can see
your penis
what
you look like you're going to a jojo fan
meet up oh my god my flies are undone
from komi-san can't communicate we now
have aharon saan is indecipherable
another feel-good comedy about a cute
little girl who can only verbalize
herself by speaking fluent asmr now the
new waifu category popping up i like to
call professional mouth breathers you
know with the gimmick that her voice is
so quiet they're not a single person
could even hear her i don't know why
they didn't just go ahead and call this
a silent voice
there's also super sentai romantic
comedy where red ranger fell in love
with the villainous and they have to
continue their relationship in secret by
pretending to be enemies it's your
typical standard star-crossed lovers
with the tokusatsu twist you know with
the gaming that they're dating but also
have to pretend that they're in combat
with each other i don't know why they
didn't just go ahead and call this love
is war for [ __ ] there's an anime where
poor girl accidentally joins an agency
and becomes the manager of a bunch of
stuck up guys who are popular but also
complete [ __ ]
i believe the agency was called geeks
plus we got another demon academy
wannabe i don't know why these
reincarnated demon lords are even trying
when anna's voting already exists i mean
look we got giga chad annos beats a man
to death with his heartbeat collects a
harem immediately yields a castle into
nani and even melts at cinderella's
heart in two episodes and then you have
this guy reincarnated demon lord most
powerful being on earth
can't speak to girls at this rate i
wouldn't be surprised if he changed his
pronouns from he him to just he
cause he'll never be him
[Music]
here's a wild card for you we've got a
bloody musical anime this season around
girls who can heal people with the power
of singing which made me realize i don't
think we've had a musical anime before
characters will just randomly break out
into song instruments magically start
playing out someone's ass i'm not
typically a musical guy but i was
impressed though thinking about it i
don't know how good my outfit would be
if i just went to the doctor for a
headache and they started busting out i
dreamed a dream not enough healing for
you no worries as we've got cute little
baby ghosts to help you get through a
tough workday you know i would call this
the perfect cure for depression until i
realized that this is just senko-san
dead baby edition okay i gotta be honest
when i saw the trailer for this and
manga readers absolutely hyped this up i
was prepared for the possibility that i
could be selling all of my marin stocks
and going all in on the shikimori train
this was the potential new face of best
girl but now
look at these diamond hands baby we've
got a girlfriend who's proving to be the
most effective anti isekai weapon
developed thus far protective of a
precious little boyfriend i mean just
look at this guy tell me this isn't the
face of a man only a peg you could love
this is another show in the recent trend
of anime looking at single weebs dead in
the eye and going you will never get
this you will never get this
and look this is a cute little slice of
life but do people really think she has
a shot of taking the crown from our
queen of best girls when a gimmick is
just basically i can be your angle
or your devil maybe this will impress me
more as the series goes on but my
current forecast is to keep huddling on
marin weebs because it looks like there
isn't going to be a clear best girl this
season
all right sell everything
right now all right here's the big one
shonen jump just seems to be in a league
of its own right now every time a new
title gets adapted not only is it great
but without fail always jumps up to
become the most prominent anime of its
season and spike's family
seems to be doing exactly that the show
has quickly become the talk of the anime
community and i can absolutely see why
you got a masterfully done comedy
involving the most dysfunctional family
of all time with a spy dad and assassin
mom and a cute little girl who can read
minds taking place in the completely
fictional city of berlin man i can't
wait for them to go to london stop off
at budapest before they fly off to a
can't believe it's not paris so they can
end the journey in amsterdam daniel the
setup is absolute chaos but so far it's
delivered in almost every single aspect
from comedy to badass moments to scenes
with anya just any scenes with anya all
the scenes with anya just give me more
onions we need more anyas i'll take 10
of your finest onions give me your
entire stock of anyas this one is
looking like the full package and with
studio wits and cloverworks taking the
helm for this one this is a definite
must-watch for every anime fan out there
wait a minute where do i recognize that
room from
oh no ah yes another seasonal anime
death game called
called
squad game will you ever call me there i
was expecting this one to be some king's
game so bad it's good level of trash but
it's actually half decent these aren't
just mindless death games the amount of
game theory potential here makes this an
entertaining watch there's a group of
friends working together to decrease the
substantial debt they are sharing but of
course there's a snake in the group they
gotta weed out and you know what that
means there's only one animal that can
kill a snake
a mongoose cute girls do real estate now
here's a concept where i thought what
the [ __ ] is the target audience for this
show who's out there fantasizing about
owning real estate in a fantasy world
then i realized that this entire show
probably took less time to write to
produce an anime than it does to
actually get a house in final fantasy
14. i quit hearing i remember a few
seasons ago when realist hero aired and
i was just like oh hey a kingdom
management anime that's a pretty
original idea this is now the third one
in two seasons
and i love it i think i found my new
guilty pleasure genre cause it's like
watching a new playthrough of
civilization except i can just watch an
entire season of these anime faster than
it would take to set up and complete a
single game of civ 6
[Music]
that's literally what a pro golfer does
look i'm just going to say it golf is
boring
to watch it is just not a fun spectator
sport
that is unless you add cute anime girls
mario golf's special abilities a [ __ ]
underground golf gambling syndicate this
girl just had to drive through a [ __ ]
moving train this is golfing in the
happy gilmore universe and it is better
for it birdie wing might actually do the
impossible make golf fun to watch this
is surprisingly an anime original coming
from studio sunrise which is so out of
their ballpark because unless she told
me there was absolutely no way i could
have known that this was a studio
sunrise made show
that's time corrected trust nobody
not even yourself
trust nobody
not even your shelf
trust nobody not even your elf
sus no
summertime render now this is looking
like one of the most intriguing anime of
the season being some kind of
supernatural murder mystery you got a
bit of re-zero you've got a bit of
higurashi you've got a bit of cicadas
actually a lot of cicadas did i mention
this anime was said in the summer
it is way too early to tell how this
one's gonna play out but trust me when i
say all it takes is exactly one episode
to get you absolutely hooked just to
find out what the hell is going on here
juggling
kong ming was one of the greatest
chinese strategists of the three
kingdoms period as well as a statesman
engineer
a premise this insane should not result
in a show this good legendary ancient
chinese military strategist juggal yang
is reincarnated into modern day shibuya
where he takes an interest in inspiring
singer and decides to become her manager
where he uses war tactics from romance
of the three kingdoms to gain her
followers and popularity so she can rise
up to stardom what the [ __ ] this is an
absolute [ __ ] of ideas yet
somehow pulls everything together
without feeling like lol xd look at all
this randomness la mao the characters
the comedy the charm the opening that
slaps harder than will smith on an oscar
it's been a long time since i've fallen
for a show this fast because behind all
the insanity there is real quality to be
seen here
[Music]
somehow this has the best music
production i've seen since carat and
tuesday if i had to put money on what
would be the sleeper hit of the season
this would be it but even if it isn't
you bet your ass i'm going to be singing
this opening with the boys all the way
to the clubs
[Music]
ah a couple of cuckoos i wonder what
this is all about
[Music]
a couple of [ __ ] i was just thinking
the trashy harem romance genre needed
something new to spice it up and it
looks like we found a new contrived
setup to do just that forget childhood
friends forget teacher student
relationships forget family friendly
polygamy we now have separated a birth
arranged marriages who needs spy x
family when we've got nisiko x domestic
girlfriend going on here but you know as
much as i want to get behind this i
don't know i just feel like it's missing
some kind of secret ingredient to make
this the dumpster fire i was looking for
[Music]
this is going to be anime of the year
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too alpha
sigma basil dysfunctional degenerate
elephant flabberwocky ivito jeff lovatos
hayne patchett pony stark walter geiss
vt and everyone else my patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible look at that
guys two main channel giggup video in
two weeks
god my videos are like london buses now
i guess oh it's cause i came back to
england honestly that wasn't really
planned i just worked on both videos at
around the same time so they finished
around the same time yeah i know i
should probably schedule my workload
better right honestly though there was a
lot to talk about this season like way
more than last season i really want to
give more interesting shows more time
and maybe give more shows a bit more of
a spotlight but the first draft was
already way longer than last season's
first draft and uh i didn't have time to
make this a 20 minute video anyway
though i hope you found something good
to watch because there is a lot of
interesting [ __ ] this season that's it
from me for today i've been gig and i'll
see you all next time
[Music]